action fox news contributor dan bongino
i'm tired of this false narrative
they have a monopoly on compassion they
have a a monopoly caring for minorities
an america no they don't
donald trump set those records they
never did
yeah i i mean i i'm really astonished
how many people keep
falling for this liberal scam um it's
obviously a scam it's been a scam
forever you know i've read an
interesting book once by a fred siegel
called revolt against the masses
and he talks about the history of the
democrat party how they've always aimed
to screw over the middle class
that's always been their goal they've
always viewed them as the great unwashed
the deplorables what do we have
the smelly walmart people the democrats
have always done that and think about it
sean
there is no better example or worse
example i should say
because of the ramifications of it than
the keystone pipeline
they come into office like you said
running on this phony campaign said hey
we're all about
tolerance the middle class and the
little guy while they ram it
right up the wazoo for every middle
class worker out there you got 11 000
solid middle class jobs wiped out
because joe biden wants to kiss the ass
of the climate activists left think
about that and
you know we say all the time right well
why shouldn't the government and people
like joe biden
why should they shouldn't they pick
winners or losers because they're too
stupid to pick the winners
when have they ever picked a winner you
gave the answer of solyndra sean but the
example of government uh
government subsidized companies that
have gone under after the government got
involved
is like six thousand pages long if they
were smart enough to build a private
business themselves
they wouldn't be in government they'd be
in private business and yet these idiots
are running our lives
i mean the government can't spend other
people's money on other people
because they suck they're too stupid i
mean that's really
one more thing you know i father bob
cerrico at the accident acted as
a really smart guy he said once in a
lecture i heard him give he said
it's not that the government's too big
it's that it's too stupid
literally it just can't figure these
things out and we're letting them run
our lives and when you do this is what
happens
you have 11 000 hard-working americans
whose jobs have been flushed down the
toilet
because we handed this over to joe biden
and his cronies
you know these cold-hearted jackasses
these people this week
hard-working americans they lost career
jobs
many of them paying six figures dan
these are great jobs they have great
benefits
but no no we want you to get other good
union job okay
those good union jobs are non-existent
it's the toughest job market we've faced
because of the worst pandemic in a
hundred years
now the other thing is how about they
ground
the private jet fleet we the taxpayers
paid for
too yeah
well sean you made a great point in a
monologue i don't want the audience to
miss
number one that you're right this is
their let them eat cake moment the
democrats oh just get other jobs as if
again
they were too dumb to figure this out
for themselves oh i've got a six-figure
job maybe i should have just gotten
another job
but you brought up two great points
number one you're doing this for the
environment
that oil coming from the canadian shale
fields it's just going to come on
come in via a dirtier method via rail
what do you think the oil is going to be
shut down are you really that stupid
and secondly the russians are laughing
right now
you're gonna pump it no this is great
they're gonna pump it so let me get the
straight america you're self-sabotaging
your own economy
so that we can sell you guys more oil
nice job fellas
putin thinks this is great right now i'm
glad you brought that point up you
nailed it
yeah and we can you should ground the
fleet hey john kerry i have a message
for you
scrap your plane don't sell it because
somebody else will be leaving a carbon
footprint
i want you to take it and have it
dismantled and
show that you mean it you're going to
sacrifice like you're asking the
american worker to sacrifice
uh don't hold your breath there and pay
your taxes on that boat
pay your taxes on that boat in parks and
rhode island remember that story a few
years ago
pay your taxes on that too buddy and put
those windmills outside the kennedy
compound all right dan thank you